all right today we're talking with Kevin
Greene sales director from Humana who
are sponsors of this segment on how
Humana Medicare plans can help those
experiencing financial problems welcome
to the show my friend happy to be here
so how can how can financial problems
impact a person's health
well anytime you're thinking about your
health and your financials right if the
financials get in the way and you can't
afford the health care now you have to
make a decision you know can I afford to
put food on the table or can I afford my
prescriptions can I afford to go to the
doctor so it can cause things like you
know stress high blood pressure and you
know just Financial instability and
those are not those are situations you
want to be in what is Humana doing to
help
well we have a program we call human
care so when you think about Ximena we
want to meet the consumer exactly where
they want to be met and that starts with
affordability okay let's talk about
premiums and co-pays because I feel like
that is a big issue for a lot of people
whether you're financially struggling or
not how is Humana helping out people in
those situations well it starts with the
majority of our plans are a zero premium
okay and a lot of them carry zero
co-pays so this allows them to have
access to the health care and not worry
about the financial issues we're going
to make it affordable for them and we're
going to add other benefits too on top
of that and you guys have a lot of
innovative programs as well talk to me
about some of the Innovative programs
you guys have going on yeah well new for
23 uh there's some really expensive
prescription drugs out there one is
known as Eliquis one is known as Xarelto
Ximena on all of our plans in the state
of Nevada is covering those for less
than ten dollars okay which is
tremendous that is huge yes a lot of
people you know they have to just they
decide hey Doc I can't take this because
I can't afford it so that's just one
example well I think you start off too
when you said that you know people
having to decide whether you put food on
the table or get the prescriptions that
they need to survive and that should be
a situation that no one should be facing
that situation what are some other
benefits and programs that you guys have
going on yeah it doesn't stop there so
we also on our plans we include what's
called a silver sneakers benefit which
is a gym membership that's covered by
the plan okay so we're going to inspire
your health and well-being you know I
can't afford it's no longer an excuse
yeah yeah no excuses now you get to the
gym with it that's great because that
just leads to a healthier lifestyle yeah
and we have what's called a healthy
options card on select plans which helps
pay for groceries over-the-counter items
and additional coverage for dental
vision and hearing this is a win-win for
everyone Kevin can't beat it I
appreciate it thanks for coming on buddy
really appreciate it and thanks to
Humana for sponsoring this segment and
you can learn more at Medicare
agents.humana.com or by calling
702-837-4439 Las Vegas now we'll be
right back